si les invocamos el tango pensarán en
buenos aires- en montevideo pero desde
hace un siglo la música y danza del río
de la plata' cuenta con segunda capital
la ciudad de medellín
[Música]
cuando noches que antes tenía soledad
bienvenidos a esta especial cultura
desde la urbe de la eterna primavera
fuera del género se ignora que medellín
tenga tanto fervor por el tango y la
milonga incluso en colombia cuando ese
amor que involucró a la clase
trabajadora y a la industria disquera se
fue cocinando en los hogares y en
barrios como en guayaquil oeste el
manrique con un gran aliciente gardel
[Música]
sobre carlos gardel aún se debate si
nació en toulouse francia o en
tacuarembó uruguay pero nadie se
cuestiona que en 1917 se erigió cantor
del primer tango canción y que su noche
triste llego medellín un 24 de junio de
1935 había recibido la infusión de
bogotá e iba a seguir su gira en cali
cuando una ráfaga de viento en el
aeródromo olaya herrera hizo que su
aeronave se estrellara contra otra
antes de cantar mi última canción quiero
decir que he sentido grandes emociones
en colombia no sé si volveré pero está
el encanto de esta tierra que no puedo
decirles adiós sino hasta siempre
por una parada técnica podría haber sido
título de una de sus 770 piezas de las
llamas quisieron unirlo medellín por
siempre primero con una asociación y ya
en el 73 con este museo estilo barrio de
la boca donde se aprende que carlitos
estuvo enterrado en medellín seis meses
antes de ser repatriado argentina si
bien que fuese llevado a hombros
ferrocarril y barco no detonó lo
tanguero en el imaginario muchas
personas está que cuando gardel vino a
medellín y si muere es que el tango
empieza a sonar y no es así
incluso cartel en su visita a medellín
sabía que medellín era una ciudad tan
guera yo creo que lo hicimos tan propio
no solamente por la muerte de gardel
sino porque el tango también te canta lo
cotidiano
antes de morir cardel el tango recorría
el suelo paisa y sorprende ver las
múltiples razones de su éxito una fue el
cine argentino y mexicano de los 20 30
con el morocho del abasto como ídolo
otra conexión la señala gustavo desde el
café alaska la música venía por
intermedio de los ríos era como le
importaban y la mandan grabar a
argentina la gente se vaya pegando mucho
a este género porque desafortunadamente
o afortunadamente las letras del tango
acuña van muy bien con las vidas que
estaba viviendo la gente aquí los
desarraigos entonces se veían muy
identificados con estas letras y en ese
en ese sentido pues las acogieron y las
tomaron como propias para ellos
construido en el 37 en alaska ha visto
pasar a cinco propietarios tangueros
también a artistas que venían a esta
urbe a hacer escala o prensar discos por
la cara música colombiana o bolero por
la ve los tangos que citaban puertos
amores y angustias
así lo arrabalero que hizo nacer el
género en el cono sur tuvo su copia en
barrios como el manrique que
reinterpretaron hasta el lunfardo el
largo del tango se barrios el barrio más
tanguero que hay en medellín en este
barrio llegaron a existir más de 80
sitios de tango
yo llevo más de 50 años como de 60 años
viviendo por acá en este barrio y hoy
día mucho la cara gardeliana a bailar el
tango para mí es una diversión en mi
show y los míos
si de una mezcla afro indígena y europea
brotó el tango en el río de la plata' la
medellín de fines del siglo 19 inicios
del 20 no tardó en gestar su culto en
bares y plazas con una clara cartografía
de hecho desde el 2000 el tango es
patrimonio artístico social y cultural
de la ciudad con la casa como primera
influencia yo crecí escuchando y papá
con los tangos hasta lloraban lloraba
con unos discos especiales donde para mí
es el tango es pasión es sensualidad y
ahora que ya soy una persona adulta
veo que el cantaba como las vivencias de
las personas
para 45 bautizada como avenida
gardeliana es mítica aunque jamás lo
hubiera sido tienen ya fallecido
leonardo nieto jardón un argentino que
en esta pasión importada halló su
proyecto y motivó esta estatua que es la
tercera tras un abrazo destructivo y un
gardel irreconocible además por su don
de repostero fundó el versalles punto de
tertulia y refugio para todos sobre todo
escritores pero no se frenó ahí y
coordinó en la casa cuando él viene aquí
a medellín se da cuenta que el
movimiento tanguero aquí era muy muy
grande incluso él decía que era más
grande que la misma buenos aires- el
inicia con el primer festival
internacional de tango y trae como
invitado de honor
aníbal troilo pichuco ellos se deben
cuenta también que eran mucho más
conocidos aquí entonces muchos de ellos
se erradicaron en la ciudad como vemos
una conexión de peso la estableció el
zorzal criollo gardel pero toda historia
tiene más notas y protagonistas y ese
aire de tango como escribió manuel mejía
vallejo no podía sino desembocar en una
fiesta a la que milonga
el primer festival que se realizó en
medellín se hizo en el año 1968 de hecho
gracias a un argentino que llegó se hizo
durante 10 años ese festival se deja de
hacer y ya se vuelve por acuerdo
municipal solo es institución alice el
festival y ya este es nuestro 15º
festival
esperamos que que pueda durar mucho
tiempo y si seguimos convocando mucha
gente el festival una vez que llega a
medellín entre españa la gente malasia
bolivia uruguay chile argentina estados
unidos desde 2007 lo que empezó con leo
como cónsul amo tu propio es cita
mundial para 45.000 personas y más de
400 artistas por supuesto cada 24 de
junio se ofrenda a gardel
pero su carácter social y educativo es
su esencia con una ruta del tango por
las comunas mientras otras llevan la
fiesta a hospitales y residencias claro
que esta época kobe puso límites pero no
impidió el cultivo del tango y la
proyección del talento propio la
inauguración fue con la orquesta de la
red de escuelas donde hace 5 años 6 años
teníamos un solo bandoneonista en la
ciudad ahora contamos en la orquesta con
6 bandoneonistas y en la ciudad
tendremos alrededor de 10-12
bandoneonistas tenemos grandes artistas
no sólo de ahora sino muchos que
hicieron hay un tango que es muy
conocido que se llama lejos de ti tango
es un género que también tiene un objeto
es decir un grupo de gente que hace
parte de una red por eso hacemos los
campeonatos internacionales invitamos a
artistas internacionales entre sus temas
el propio tango ha cantado su perdida
pero viendo estas instituciones
concursantes que van de malasia chile y
clases de baile
queda claro que eso no ocurre
y aquí los jóvenes se han adueñado del
gotham el tango de una forma tradicional
es decir por la danza se iba a consumir
tango de otra manera tenías que consumir
licor esa evolución que ha tenido el
tango le ha dado entrada a la nueva
generación a un giro muy grande pero
sobre todo a la danza al baile y el
tango es unos viajes diferentes por el
tango nunca se va a morir y menos con
músicos como lautaro greco no fue por
abel de jota salazar julio erazo o josé
noel ramírez compositores y cantores
colombianos de tango que greco abrazó el
bandoneón fue por su compatriota astor
piazzolla cuyo centenario de su
natalicio no solo ha sido centro de este
festivo sino opereta y concierto junto a
la orquesta filarmónica ya solas
me fascinó en el momento que lo encontré
y lo estudie a fondo la verdad es que el
bandoneón es un instrumento muy joven un
instrumento que tiene mucho para dar
está muy poco explorado entonces yo creo
que todavía hay mucho por encontrar y un
poco está bueno
está bueno siempre seguir investigando
en ciertas cosas como es estar tocando
el bandoneón que no es tan conocido no
afuera de latinoamérica y bueno lo que
tenemos nosotros los argentinos es que
tenemos una historia corta que son 100
años pero con unos músicos increíbles
que realmente en algún punto se
inventaron el instrumento el instrumento
fue pensado para tocar música
clásica o música así tipo coral y se
encontró otro destino completamente
distinto en el caso del tango y del
bandoneón por suerte pude profundizar
porque vengo desde familia pero también
un poco el desafío es ese no es como
poder
ver todo lo que hay y sintetizar algo de
este estudio de piaf hola qué hacéis con
el que intento revolucionario del que
hace es parte cómo es ese proceso además
que es grupal no porque sí ya sola
encarnaba el mismo esa lucha como se
hace desde el bandoneón pero con todo el
grupo del gente tema no es cierto que se
hace entre todos se hace tocando mucho
bueno la música la gastamos creo que los
cinco miembros del quinteto somos
fanáticos de esta música y también se
busca digamos hacer que suene como
sonaría hoy la música de piazzolla no es
cierto es como que se va se va llenando
de alguna forma se va adaptando a los
tiempos que corren
cómo describirías el tango pelé ido
decir como en deseo esa fuerza un poco
adolescente como la de escribir y bueno
eso me pasa mucho es verdad con el tango
con piazzolla es una música con mucha
polenta es una música muy profunda parte
al medio te hace pensar te lleva hasta
las lágrimas muchas veces
incluso mezclarse con otros géneros y
siempre va a conservar algo un código
oculto de tempo de rítmica de
intenciones que son muy específicas del
tango y eso me parece que es algo que no
va nunca a perder valor no siempre va a
sumar como contagiarlo y no digo que
esté muriendo pero como hacerlo llegar a
las generaciones
digamos que todas las músicas todos los
géneros están un poco en una situación
parecida
no es lo que era muy popular en otro
momento ya no lo es tanto ya es como más
de leeds se quiere o de nicho
pero también está dentro de todo eso
está el amor de la gente por por el arte
entonces me parece que eso no hay forma
de que el tango muera sí creo que por
ahí a veces lo que pasa es que se tiene
como una nostalgia de la época de oro de
los 40 iván a eso como todo en la
historia las cosas pasan una vez y
después son distintas cuando vuelven se
transforman y hay que en pocas a las
paces con eso
has estado junto a ricardo montaner que
de eso se ha ganado un grammy también
desde esta posición como es encontrarte
una ciudad como medellín en colombia que
sea pan tanguera pan milonguera se
desinfla esto del sur es la tercera vez
que vengo pero la verdad que cada vez
que vengo sigo este impactado porque es
a veces hasta más popular acá que en el
mismo buenos aires porque se escucha en
las calles y es algo que todavía no me
acostumbro pues la ventana ha sido un
placer encontrarte no sé si podrías
porfavor tocarnos el bandoneón el
sagrado bandoneón
[Música]
en medellín quienes siento en el tango
dicen que es reflejo de la vida a pocos
metros donde murió gardel despedimos
este viaje y damos gracias a la
secretaria de cultura de la alcaldía por
abrirnos sus puertas y aunque lionel
tras cámaras y yo hemos visto algún que
otro paso mejor nos dejamos con los
profesionales gracias y cuídense mucho
[Música]